[Música]
quando me mudei para portugal e decidiu
reservar um apartamento provisório para
poder procurar com calma
o local definitivo do brasil eu vi fotos
do sítio pela internet mas não conseguia
andar a cozinha
eu mandei a mensagem o dono perguntei
não consigo ver cozinha equipada e
respondeu sim claro está equipada em
frigorífico tem máquina de café tem até
varinha mágica
vale o que meu querido por toda a gente
aqui esse é um diálogo parece
perfeitamente normal eu sei pra mim que
nunca havia morado em portugal varinha
mágica exclusivamente isso é a única
coisa que me veio à mente naquele
momento foi você tem de fato uma dessas
o preço até que não está mal
vou ser sincero com você demorar um
pouco mais de tempo do que devia para
perceber que a varinha mágica só podia
ser outra coisa eu me mudei para o
apartamento e usei varinha mágica ótimo
produto não fazia magia mas fazer assumo
detox eu gostei tanto que quando eu fui
pro apartamento definitivo decide
comprar uma
na busca por uma varinha mágica eu fiz o
que qualquer pessoa faz foi pesquisar o
produto na internet
uma das coisas que é possível notar essa
imagem são as estrelinhas embaixo do
produto eo número lado das estrelinhas
isso indica que o produto foi avaliado
por alguém e o número é a quantidade de
pessoas que fizeram a avaliação
muita gente confia nessas avaliações
para definir se compra ou não se é a
seguinte avaliação uma estrelinha não
compensa varinha mágica com pra mim ela
explodiu eu não vou arriscar uma varinha
mágica que explode
ela já não faz magia e ainda explode por
outro lado houve uma única variação
positiva mesmo que seja uma só é
possível mudar o curso da história densa
de outras tantas
veja o caso da giovana pereira de
custóias joão pereira tem 49 anos é
engenheiro na wai chi chuan o carro do
jogo é um de 92 6 jovana joana pereira
robadey repto com o cartão de crédito
que ela usa para fazer compras
quem quiser pode anotar ela não se
incomoda tá é um visa 4532 eu vou fazer
mais fácil colocar todos os dados da
jogando aqui pra quem quiser copiar o
cartão de crédito dela esse número
começa com 4 532 código de segurança 0
35 cartão vale até março de 2021 a uma
série de informações sobre o jogo
digamos que giovanna tenha deixado uma
avaliação no mesmo site que eu estou
pesquisar
digamos que ela tem escrito cinco
estrelas magnífica faz tudo
perfeitamente resolvi o problema
magnífica perfeitamente não
tudo isso seria ótimo se não fosse um
detalhe a joana pereira de custóias não
é uma pessoa real
ela não existe a giovanna resultado de
um perfil falso gerado como a imensa
quantidade de detalhes por um site
gratuito que só existe para isso gerar
perfis falsos
essa geovana por exemplo eu fiz ontem à
noite em casa quatro cliques 30 segundos
escolhi a origem do nome do país gênero
idade e clique em direito só isso
todo o resto endereço e mail profissão
número do cartão todas as outras
informações são falsas geradas pelo site
portanto a giovana pereira fake e se ela
tivesse realmente deixado qualquer
avaliação sobre qualquer produto essa
avaliação seria tão fake quanto é um mas
quem se der ao trabalho de fazer isso
gerar perfis falsos além de mim
aparentemente muita gente existe um
universo de click fármacos ou como
alguns chamam fábrica de likes
ninguém tem a mínima idéia de onde são
onde estão hoje quantas delas sejam
porque as fábricas likes ocupam um
espaço mínimo podem existir praticamente
em qualquer lugar
nos últimos cinco anos inúmeras fábricas
ou aix foram descobertas e fechadas na
tailândia camboja banco a 10 macedônia
essa da tailândia por exemplo fechado
recentemente operava com 500 telemóveis
e 400 mil 5
antes o que significa 400 mil números de
telefone diferentes a serviço da criação
de perfis falsos mas porque alguém tem
uma estrutura desse tamanho dinheiro
eles vendem o serviço e assim contribui
há quem compre fãs no facebook por 200
euros
há quem compre retuítes por 800 euros
vários sites oferecem a venda de likes
seguidores e perfis fãs
quem precisar do exército feito nem
precisa procurar muito porque até no
ebay a esse tipo de oferta
claro que há outras operações muito mais
sofisticadas
no ano passado uma reportagem do new
york times mostrou que uma empresa bem
influente vendia clientes vidas
seguidores no twitter visualizações no
youtube e até recomendações
profissionais no linkedin
depois da divulgação da reportagem a
empresa publicou um aviso dizendo que
não aceitava mais novos clientes mas ela
continua em operação não só ela continua
em operação como ela oferece
alternativas a quem precisa do serviço e
essas empresas alternativas fazem
exatamente a mesma coisa
criar um exército de perfis falsos capaz
de tudo na internet desde tarefas
simples como inflacionar o número de
seguidores em redes sociais
a atividade um pouco mais complexas como
debater com pessoas reais no twitter e
espalhar notícias falsas em qualquer
plataforma facebook instagram bote zap
tenham em mente que onde a fake news
há um exército fake e muito
provavelmente alguma definição bem
distorcida do que é de fato fectrans
pois ao contrário do que políticos
celebridades e o cristiano ronaldo
repetem todos os dias
fake news não é nem sinônimo de calúnia
nem discurso pra mim o mimado a não
gostei dessa notícia que saiu contra mim
o termo fake não significa apenas o
seguinte alguém inventou uma informação
falsa
de preferência completamente descolado
da realidade embrulhou em um papel
jornalístico e distribuiu como se fosse
verdade as minhas favoritas papa proíbe
católicos de votarem hillary clinton
robert de niro muda de lado e decidiu
apoiar tudo isso para dar dois exemplos
reais de notícias falsas
esses exemplos são direção americana de
de lá pra cá tudo piorou
assustadoramente
mais grave ainda hoje para você criar um
site uma notícia falsa nem precisa de um
site de phishing news
basta uma imagem que pareça jornalística
e transmitir a mensagem
o objetivo é fazer com que essa mensagem
chegue a pessoas reais porque são as
pessoas reais vão passar a notícia falsa
diante e da credibilidade ela isso
acontece em qualquer plataforma
mas ocorre muito mais rapidamente em
programas de mensagem instantânea
commodities a vamos fazer prático
digamos que eu querer criar uma notícia
falsa uma notícia qualquer
não é a preferência a ninguém não tem
nenhum interesse em promover ninguém eu
faço que cria uma imagem que pareça
jornalística
eu tenho certeza que a minha mãe vai
achar que se trata de um ano de ser
muito verdadeira e vai espalhar em todos
os grupos e o desafio dos quais ela faz
parte mas eu tenho uma tia desconfiada
que vai achar que a mentira vai mandar
pro meu primo para perguntar se é
verdade
e esse é um erro que muitos não percebem
mesmo com a melhor das intenções e
admitidos mascará a minha tia está só
contribuindo para espalhar ainda mais a
notícia
até que meu primo quando recebe a
mensagem dela tá tomando uns copos ele
nem percebe a ironia e também acha que é
verdade isso para nos grupos dos quais
ele faz parte e eu jamais teria acesso e
essa é uma corrente sem fim
agora vamos imaginar toda essa
engenharia potencializado em escala
profissional
as últimas eleições no brasil ficaram
famosas por terem exposto os eleitores
há uma quantidade imensa de notícias
falsas em uma escala jamais vista
dois motivos para isso o primeiro é que
a batalha eleitoral brasileiro ocorreu
quase que exclusivamente nos telemóveis
o grosso da campanha a não estava nos
comícios na televisão nem na internet
tradicional estava ali na privacidade do
telemóvel então receber e enviar com
partilhar uma notícia duvidosa era uma
atividade privada quase secreta
embora privada era sempre acompanhado de
habeas corpus preventivo não sei se é
verdade mas estou repassando o segundo
motivo imagina que uma empresa contrata
mil pessoas e cada uma delas esteja
encarregada de administrar 50 perfis
falsos por dia como aquele perfil da
joana
durante o período contratado seis meses
antes da eleição
haverá 50 mil perfis ativos
basta imaginar o estádio do dragão
lotado mas lembrem-se são perfis falsos
então o estádio do dragão lotado com que
adeptos do benfica a agora vocês
perceberam drama finalmente haverá 50
mil perfis ativos que vão estar
diariamente distribuindo notícias falsas
notícias ap
comentando em redes sociais e tentando
influenciar pessoas reais
empresas como essa que eu acabei de
escrever se disfarçam de serviços de
marketing digital
em alguns casos elas criam e administra
um grupo de um assalto em outros elas
entram em grupos que já existem enviam
aos utilizadores mais de mil mensagens
por dia criando um efeito dominó o que
no brasil é um efeito dominó dignas
porque o país é o quarto e uso
proporcional de what's up no mundo com
mais de 120 milhões de utilizadores o
que as pessoas fazem essa quantidade
absurda de fake news pôde ignorar podia
deitar na sanita várias opções mas não
elas passam adiante
há várias pesquisas que tratam do real
alcance dos pequenos mas as duas que
normalmente são citadas quando se toca
nesse tema
o primeiro é um levantamento dos blues
fita que fez três meses que antecederam
a eleição americana as 26 mil de uma
audiência tiveram mais engajamento foram
mais compartilhadas do que os 20
notícias verdadeiras maior audiência e o
estudo é mais se o maior já feito sobre
o tema realizado no ano passado analisou
quatro milhões de tweets e também
constatou que as franquias são muito
mais compartilhado com as notícias
verdadeiras mas por que isso acontece
tem uma explicação
o que nem estuda emitir nem aportar no
brasil mostra que há uma razão clara
para seguir os animais compartilhadas
pequenos não é uma obra do acaso é um
fenômeno meteorológico
lamentavelmente este mês choveu muito
mais pequeno do que estava previsto não
é isso
eu fui à serra da estrela em janeiro não
vi fé em deus como no ano passado no
tempo eles na imensa maioria das vezes
ver que existem interesses por detrás
elas foram criadas para alcançar um
objetivo você for lá elas foram criadas
para alcançar dois objetivos o primeiro
é enganar você
o segundo é fazer com que você
compartilhe e ajude enganar mais pessoas
não é só um trabalho sujo eles querem
que vocês trabalham de graça também não
importa se o álbum eleição no brasil as
eleições americanas
o black sete os próximas legislativas
portuguesas não se iludam pode ocorrer
em qualquer lugar então em quem podemos
confiar para combater os efeitos a
várias organizações dedicadas e checá
las e denunciá las e elas de fato fazer
um trabalho bem importante
a frança chefe de uma das mais
importantes do mundo e coordena projetos
em diversos países e aqui em portugal
recentemente teve o lançamento do
polígrafo que têm esse mesmo objetivo
combater notícias falsas
em caso de dúvidas sobre a veracidade de
uma informação esse talvez seja um dos
melhores sítios para saber se a notícia
é verdadeira ou não
mas isso não responde completamente a
pergunta eu sei que nós podemos confiar
mesmo antes eu quero contar um segredo é
saber quem não tem muito interesse em
combater esse fenômeno até tem mas não
com muito afinco o poder público que
adora a possibilidade de disfarçar parte
dos seus absurdos na fumaça das
femininas e alguns veículos de notícias
verdadeiras
todos eles vêm passando por uma crise de
confiança histórica ea popularização não
apenas das femininas mas o termo feio
nos fez com que eles recuperassem parte
dessa confiança e assinantes digitais
então todas as vezes que o jornal
tentasse vender como a cura para cerca
de 1.000 saibam que o benefício mútuo
ok então em quem podemos confiar por
sorte há uma fórmula matemática para
resolver esse problema
confia apenas em quem é 100% prejudicado
e 0% beneficiado e só uma resposta certa
para isso apenas em nós mesmos perfis
falsos avaliações falsas notícias falsas
tudo isso faz estragos dom urosa mente
raias
esse conjunto de feita uma de pura
democracia altera o curso da história
promove racismo xenofobia homofobia
misoginia contra pessoas reais e sendo
bem sincero tenta fazer todos nós
derrotas
a única maneira de combater isso a
exercer exercitar e principalmente
ensinar o pensamento crítico
desconfiaram apenas as notícias
suspeitas mas de todas as notícias e
discursos informações e até daquela
avaliação da minha imagem e mais
importante do que isso
duvidou não compartilhem absolutamente
nada porque nesse universo de felix a um
poder real que é nossa é a nossa varinha
mágica e essa faz magia o nosso poder de
não interagir com isso não vou
compartilhar shakeel femininos
[Aplausos]